الزلزال زلزال تركيا وسوريا وهذه الصور
مشاهدينا مباشره من مطار غازي عنتاب
التركي حيث من المفترض ان تتواجد وزيره
الخارجيه والداخليه الالمانيتين في عمليه
تسليم المساعدات الالمانيه عاقبه الزلزال
المدمر الذي طال تركيا اذا هذه صور مباشره
من مطار غازي عنتاب لوصول المساعدات
الالمانيه هذه المساعدات التي تسلم بوجود
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انلينا وزيره
الداخلي ايضا ناسي فيزا الخلاله عمليه
تسليم المساعدات الالمانيه عقب الزلزال
المدمر الذي طال تركيا
وكذلك ايضا اجزاء من سوريا في السادس من
فبراير الماضي الزلزال الذي ضرب بقوه
7.8 على مقياس اختر طبعا
وزيرتات الداخليه
الخارجيه ظاهرتان في الصوره الان امامكم
في هذه الطائره الالمانيه التي تحمل
مساعدات اضافيه وانسانيه المانيا المانيا
وصلت الى
المطار مطار غازي عنتاب في تركيا
اذا هذه صور للمساعدات وطبعا تابعنا
واياكم خلال الايام الماضيه وفي طبعا
متابعه العربيه لادق تفاصيل هذا الزلزال
الوصول مساعدات اغاثيه وانسانيه دوليه
وامميه وايضا كذلك من دول
اقليميه كذلك وهذه احد ايضا المساعدات
التي وصلت بحضور وزيرتي الداخليه
والخارجيه الالمانيتين